i told this story to jonathan davis the
lead singer of corn
about how at the download festival like
before we got off stage
whoever the next band is throw all these
eggs and we gave out like hundreds of
crates of eggs yeah do you remember
trying to get in a fight with the oh the
electric six
yeah yeah well like um so i think
it it was a shortened set because it was
a festival show and so
you were going to like have like someone
from the audience get egg but then
it couldn't happen so you told them that
egg the next band
and it happened to be the electric six
thank god it wasn't pennywise
which was the band after the only one
took six we knew them but they would
have kicked our asses
and and also like i mean i was friends
with some of them
but um but anyway so is the electric six
and and
from my point of view like what i wasn't
it
there but i guess they got egged in and
it was pretty gnarly like the whole time
and um the guy you you came up to me and
you told me like exactly
this guy threw a beer on me except it
landed on my girl
i was literally a girl i had a date with
me and he threw beer on me
but he got it on my girl and i told
chris the truth
he tell you the truth that girl was kind
of a [ __ ] but but
he disrespected you and in my eyes he
started trouble with with my friend
in in um yeah i remember pontius looked
at me said are you
is are you telling the truth like you're
not lying about this right because
if you're if you're if you tell me that
this really happened and and
it's true then i'll address this matter
yeah like as whenever when everyone like
would stick me on somebody like as long
as it like
like there's been a few times like yeah
where like you know like
um a friend of mine or a female friend
would like be harassed you know and
and you know and want something you know
something would need to be done about it
but yeah you were serious you were
distraught yeah absolutely definitely
serious luckily i had my wrestling
singlet on on
like under my clothes you put it on you
put it on special yeah
i put my wrestling singlet on and i went
i went to up to them
into their whole trailer he said i want
to fight all six of you but the electric
six it's not six guys
[Laughter]
yeah i want to fight all six of you and
uh and the guy the guy opens up the
curtain just
like a little bit and pawnee is punches
through the glass now pontius is
bleeding everywhere
and then they send all the festival
security to come over and they [ __ ]
locked us
in our trailer well we just couldn't get
out so we just start peeing all over it
like
breaking breaking everything they they
put um they
when when i started like um you know
telling them
trying to start a fight with the
electric six they put them into a
trailer that trailer though
and wanted them just to like get
distance from me and then
so then at the window like the guy the
guy he antagonized me he opened the
blinds
he flipped me off he gave me a taste of
his little fingers that's why i punched
through it it gave me a taste of it
that's right jesus yeah
yeah dude